I lied about all this for probably like
6 months. Okay.
But he's just lying. He's like a lazy,
lying, disgusting
pervert, disgusting weirdo. The logo of
the server is a skull that has the
letters CPS written on it. Yes. These
people have a hyperbolic time chamber to
analyze all of the content that's
happening and to snark all of it, okay?
Oh
my
>> [laughter]
>> What a day. What a day it is. Is it not
an auspicious day? Is it not?
You please just explain the situation.
Okay, so there is a clipping Discord
that I'm a part of, okay? It's been
there for a while. I have substances in
it. Um
Couple people here are in it.
Right? And we post Basically, I will ask
for links to stuff. Uh I will suggest
clips to people. I'll retweet other
people's clips. Right? And there's a
bunch of community or there's a bunch of
creators in there.
And that's what I use that for is I just
use it to go over clips, to retweet
clips. It's like and and talk about
content. Like it's talking about content
and sharing opinions. Hey, what's your
opinion on this drama? What do you think
about this? Giving an argument, right?
And calling everything snark is so
disingenuous. Yeah. So this is Discord.
It's like um semi-private. I don't know
how you'd quite talk about it. It's like
semi-private. It's around 100 people.
It's invite-only.
I know that it's going to be public
eventually, so I talk in there like I
will be
I will be offensive in there. I will say
offensive things.
But overall, it's really nothing, right?
Anyway, so there's a bunch of creators
in there and yeah, we talk about [__]
We laugh. We have a good time.
And basically, they're trying to post
like cut up logs with absent any context
as if this is like an evil doxing
server. Destiny wants this to go and
flow into his greater narrative that I'm
running like a cabal that's been working
against him that hates him and wants to
undermine everything he's ever done.
All right, maybe we start off with the
spider Twitter. We'll go through some of
these clips.
It's like Lunar Box clips on here.
There's also spider like leaking these
logs from this Discord. I might have to
go to some Hutch thing. I do want to get
this I want to get this out cuz Hutch
lied about something specifically.
And I don't know why he did this.
I really I don't.
I don't know well, sorry. At least from
what I could tell it seems like he lied.
And that was basically when he tried to
paint the Discord as as people who are
like
as soon as as soon as people or Hutch
tried to paint this Discord as someone
that was like talking about his sister
who is passed away
and like on her or like trying to [__]
on him because of his sister or
something.
Uh that's where it got weird for me or
at least I can't see anything in there
that is anything like this. I would
totally shut that down. Like I obviously
don't like collateral attacks at all.
I always shut that stuff down.
So he painted it that way and
I like I feel like I have to show people
what the logs are around it.
What do you put up here? Got to say I'm
not terribly surprised to have found
this in the leak snark Discord logs.
Folks, this is online politics. If
you're invoking dead family members of
this stuff, you're years overdue for
extensive therapy, delete your accounts,
and reevaluate.
>> [clears throat]
>> So
I don't know what the context of this
was. If I saw somebody say this around
me, I'd be like you're a psycho, you're
like crazy, you're I like what the [__]
is wrong with you?
You know what I'm saying?
But the conversation I can find in the
logs
is this one.
But basically I can read it off.
Somebody was like making a video about
Hutch and it's like this is the
conversation around it. Thinking about
whether or not to include a mention of
Hutch's sister passing away and the
effect it had on his on him and it feels
like I should. It seems like it was a
big turning point in his life and led to
him getting his diagnosis. 7:05 in the
video and he posts some video of Hutch
talking about his bipolar diagnosis. And
then the person says, "And he talked
about it with Dr. K a lot about dealing
with it and it was a big change."
And
there's apparently a joking poll that
says, "Should Tony's Should Should this
guy snark Hutch's dead sister?"
And it's all no. So, like that that
sounds like a joke, but immediately the
responses to it are, "Hey, no no no, I
don't think you should mention this or
or like joke about it at all." Right?
And the guy's like, "Yeah, I don't want
to joke about it at all. I'm not joking
about it at all. Like, it's just
important. I would I wouldn't snark her.
I would just mention it as a dark time
in his life in the biography section."
And the person says, "Maybe let Hutch
speak for himself on how it affected
him." And he's like, "Yeah, I was
thinking of including a short clip or
two about him talking about it and how
he felt how he felt afterwards." So,
like to me, I'm like, "That's tasteful.
It's like not even
That's not even like it's literally just
somebody talking about they wanted to
make a video on Hutch. And they're like,
"Oh, for like leading into who Hutch is,
uh this is how I I would frame it or
this is I think it's important. I don't
think it's something I leave out."
It was never about attacking her or
anything like that.
So, I don't know where this is from.
I've not seen this.
But, it's totally absent context
somehow.
I
Okay. Anyway, all right. I'll show those
I'll show those chat messages in just a
little bit. We just need to redact them
first.
Okay.
Did someone brought it up in the live
and learn chat like coordinating, I
believe. I haven't gone back and
listened to his stream again, though.
Does he have proof of that? Cuz from
what I what I heard, and I haven't seen
logs of this, but from what I heard,
someone asked Someone was actually
annoyed about it and I think they asked
if anybody in that Discord was doing it
and everybody said no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So, I'm saying that
I've seen no proof that anyone in that
Discord would do that.
In fact, I think most people are not
fans of that.
Now,
could there be like a who did it on some
alt account
and then lied?
I don't know how to control for that.
No, I don't I I hope not. I make it very
clear this kind of [__] is not cool.
Right? Like there is a there is a mean
nature to some of the the commentary.
There's a mean nature to it.
I'm not I'm not going to lie to you
guys. Like it's it's mean. It's like
mean girl like snarky commentary. Just
like you'd expect on some snark
subreddit or people talking [__] on
Twitter or anywhere, right? It's mean.
Yes.
But essentially what this is all going
to boil down to is these people are
being really mean about me.
That's what this all is. These people
are like really mean. Oh.
Okay. Pearl clutching is no carry
anymore. What's this Yeah, that's all it
was was pearl clutching. They're all
just like oh, these people are really
These people are really mean and they
have like
They spend all their time doing this.
You ain't got a hobby, man?
Imagine not having passion for anything
and then decrying and degrading
denigrating other people's passion. You
don't got any You got any any hobbies
that you're passionate about, man?
My hobby happens to be
watching low IQ political streamers and
laughing at them and calling them stupid
in a Discord. That's my hobby, man. I
don't know what am I supposed to do?
It's Is it a healthy hobby? Is it a
bleeding of more productive society?
Nah. Nah, it's not. It's not.
>> [laughter]
>> But it is it is fun and it actually
not even arguably, it absolutely helps
me with my job. Like I just Dude, you
have no idea how much it helps when I've
just watched like a bunch of adjacent
content to something and it just informs
me telling a story.
Right? It's just It's like required to
tell a story.
All right, let's watch this clip of Dan
and Mouton on anything else.
Ethan Klein is the number one person
they hate in there. The number two
person they This is Dan talking about
this Discord, okay? Now,
as with any Discord, could there be
somebody who does something really
wrong, really bad,
and needs to be punished for that,
right? Like, we have there's there's an
absolute no doxing rule. There's like a
bunch there
and
the rules are enforced. The only person
I know of who had done doxing stuff in
there
was banned.
This clip is funny to me because we talk
about a bunch of different drama and
stuff in there. And Destiny's presenting
this is like evidence of the cabal
against him. The cabal that's pro-Hasan
and against him,
right?
And it turns out Destiny's not even the
most not even in the most top the top
three most snark people in the server.
Like, the people who get talked about
the most, Destiny's not even in the top
three, according to Dan.
It's so funny, man. Ethan Klein is the
number one person they hate in there.
The number two person Ethan Klein,
number one. they hate in there is
Nicholas DeOrio. Do you want to Number
two is Nicholas DeOrio. Oh, okay. The
third person they hate in there? You.
Who It's Destiny, right? Cuz it's the
cabal against Destiny.
No.
Some
s- trans streamer I've never heard of
called TransFirebat.
I have no
There's a dedicate So, if you don't
know, this is something of an inside
joke on that server. Is there a people
who care about this tiny creator who
feuds with Purple Perry Gaming,
right? And
the joke is the the like I think
me and Kweebman have at least a couple
times made a comment something along the
lines of like, "Bro, are you guys
serious with the like with with this
call with this TransFirebat call? Like,
are you are you serious right now?"
There was one time like some big content
had gone down and nobody had like talked
about it, nobody had saved the streams,
nobody had done anything. It's just
like, "Bro,
why are there 50 clips of this stupid
person with 20 viewers and you guys
aren't YOU GUYS AREN'T GOING AND DOING
anything about it. It's so dumb.
I I've personally advocated multiple
times for the people talking about this
person or this drama to be banned from
the Discord. Not on any like moral
grounds, not on anything like saying
it's wrong because I don't want to see
it.
Off with this stupid person. I don't
care. I don't care.
I'm not like against people watching
some creator
but holy [__] Off, I don't want to see
it. It's so boring. It's so stupid.
The idea of Dan sifting through
gigabytes and gigabytes of transfirebat
like archive streams or commentary on
their stream. Like that is dude, yeah,
he's in the [__] coal mines right
now. Dan Dan has been banished to the
coal mines. He's going to have to look
through all of those. What the What are
they talking about? What are they
talking about? Dude.
Yeah, it's going to be funny, man. It's
going to be Anyway, so I just want to
point out that Destiny is not even hated
enough by this server to be more talked
about than transfirebat. It's not
Destiny.
It's not Dan.
It's not Hutch.
It's transfirebat.
[__]
trans streamer I've never heard of
called transfirebat.
I have no They There is a dedicated like
gangstalking operation for this I I've
never even heard of this person before
and these I I'm not even joke I'm you're
looking at me saying who and that's I
thought that I was losing my mind cuz I
saw firebat. I was like, we talking
about Starcraft here? Is this code name
of something? That's how [__] crazy
it is. Yeah, they'll be like Wow.
>> I don't know. I don't think it's it's
not the it's not the Hearthstone guy. I
looked at that also. I don't it's not
firebat the Hearthstone guy. It's
literally like I can't find [__] about
this person. It's just like some
Dan RACKING HIS BRAIN TRYING TO find
trans fire bad content. Oh my god.
Nobody trans person that they're all
obsessed with a logging and harassing.
It's kind of crazy. It's uh
it's very weird and creepy. I Post the
logs of me advocating for all of those
people to be banned cuz they waste my
time. I'm
Like it's to the point where I'm like,
okay, Claude is acting up uh as I go
through this. It's It can't be that many
messages about this person. It's weird.
It's very weird. It's a very, very
weird. They're very, very weird people.
They're very obsessive. They're very
They're stalkers.
That's the thing you have to know is
that this this server
it's not based around from what I've
seen so far. It's not based around
activism. It's not based around doing
anything good or having a positive
influence. They don't Wait, what? What
do you mean? What do you mean it's not
based around having a positive
influence?
I What How are you arguing
This guy is trying to Dan Saltman is
personally making it his mission to with
Abdullah Sayid. That's what his personal
mission is, okay?
So much so that he wrote a an article in
the Free Press about him. All right?
That's Dan's mission right now.
Let's keep going.
We'll watch This is all of them talking
about the same Discord, okay? Multiple
streams from Hutch, Lonerbox, Connor,
Destiny, all talking about this same
stream. Oh, Dan and Mr. Mouton all talk
about the same
like Clipper Discord and people being
mean in it, okay?
Lonerbox jokes about selling the
uh
files amid ongoing drama.
They're not a fan of like Destiny or Dan
or whatever. So, I was like, okay, wait,
wait. Actually, maybe it turns out I do
have a kind of unique access here. Then
I thought, wait.
Let's think about this. There are These
people have upset a lot of very wealthy
individuals. So, I just put out some
feelers yesterday, you know? I was like,
"Okay, who are the wealthiest people I
know that these guys really don't like
and these people are talking?" So, I
kind of went through, you know, it was
Okay.
I'm trying to make peace with Lonerbox,
so I'm not going to go in on him very
much today.
But, this is a kind of psychotic thing
to do, no?
Like, I thought he was joking. Did he
actually put out feelers or is this just
a joke? Maybe it's just a joke. Maybe
after the clip he says it's just a joke
or something. This would be totally
psychotic if this is what he's actually
>> saying. Usual suspects, you know, your
Dans, your Ethans. You know, I messaged
I messaged Destiny as well. I was like,
"Hey brother, listen. I know we've had
our differences, but uh some He's got to
be joking.
>> times, you know, uh mutual uh mutual
interests,
wink wink.
And, you know, I thought I would like
make them make them feel like they were
the only ones getting these messages,
you know, a bit of manipulation. And, uh
you know, there's uh turns out there was
a highest bidder. Um
you can guess who. So,
I'm sitting on a solid 20k right now. I
don't know what I'll do with it. Maybe
go on holiday somewhere, some type of
[__] Uh it's out of my hands though,
you know? Good good luck.
I feel like this
is like obviously a joke to me.
No, I said I literally said I don't know
if this is true. I assume it's a joke.
If it's not a joke, everything I think
about Lonerbox is wrong.
Uh what's the punchline? So, when I say
joke, maybe I shouldn't say joke.
I think Lonerbox feels personally
slighted, and so he's saying this to try
to inspire fear or or angst in the
people who have who have slighted him,
who have upset him.
And, this isn't like a sincere
expression of intent or of action, but
something that you do like in a petty
fashion out of spite to make people
worried that you're you're helping their
enemies.
You know what I mean? That's so not a
joke, just not sincere. Right?
When he said he messaged Destiny about
it, I'm like, "No, you didn't." I I'm
pretty confident you didn't. Pretty
confident.
I [laughter] In other news, uh
okay, no, actually I all the I guess all
the people who messaged me last night
with something to say about this whole
thing.
I mean, you've given me a lot to think
about. That's that's nice. Uh
I
I think somebody offered him money and
he's joking about that. Yeah, he's
coming back. Yeah, yeah. He's not saying
he sold anything. He was he was
basically doing a bit.
>> is
whoever is giving it to me is giving it
to other people. Cuz it's
it's pretty straight straightforward.
There's not much I can do.
I kind of wonder, would Luna be at all
worried
that not just
I I hope he would be worried or think
about the idea
that he could have possibly been given
something specifically to upset him, to
turn him against people.
Right? That the person who is the third
party has been leaking him stuff might
not be leaking everything to him first.
I hope he thought about this.
Just saying. In a general sense.
Not really my thing.
I don't fancy
>> Okay, well. Okay, this is the next one.
What is this clip? Let's answer for it.
Let's take a look.
>> be way less likely to
to
to [clears throat] be like now I'm just
suspicious.
Now I'm just suspicious. So like
it's going to be
I'm going to be way less likely to
engage in in this kind of like
attempts at manipulation. I sent
kind of like troll chatters, some people
call them snarkers. They usually hang
out in the like the J stock, Queenman,
sometimes in peace ghost community. They
show up here every now and then. They
show up in soy pills. Like what is going
on with your life if you're hyper
focused on, you know, like
small to mid-size
like politics streamers.
Is that
Oh, sorry. Ethan Klein, Nicholas Yorio,
trans fire bat. Maybe The funny thing
here is, to be honest
To be honest with you, um it's very
funny to me cuz
in my opinion in my opinion
Hutch just underestimates how creepy and
obsessed people can be. Like, he's not
in the top three according to whatever
AI Dan used. He's not in the top three.
And dude, this I swear to god Hutch's
entire stream this morning or the parts
I watched are
There's a There's a group of people who
are surveilling me. They're watching all
of my streams. There's like 12 people
watching all of my streams. And then
it's like, Hutch is live to 450 viewers
right now. I don't know if you know
this, but there's more than 12 people
watching all of your streams. There's
way more than 12 actually.
They like watch my streams and read my
tweets and it's crazy.
Okay. I don't All right. That's
Dude, imagine the paint guy at Home
Hardware. He's like, this person brought
me a bucket. Uh they brought me a swatch
and they said between these two colors.
And then
I had to make them paint
with the color that was between those
two. It's like you're describing your
job. Yeah, that's your job is people
watch you and then they comment on your
tweets.
KJ Stahli is different than the people
who watch me disagree and dislike me.
No, it's not.
No, it's not. Everybody's got people who
watch their content and dislike them.
Hutch knows this by virtue of the fact
that he obviously caters to that exact
crowd of people who focus on Hasan.
I'm not going to say that Hutch is as
creepy or weird as some of the people in
this discord.
But he absolutely caters to the creepy
weirdos who are just like that for
Hasan.
Know that, okay? There are a bunch of
people in Hasan's chat or sorry, in
Hutch's chat who are the same kind of
obsessed creepy, weirdos, and he he's
just coping about it, okay?
Like for me, I'm not watching every
Hutch stream. I'm not watching every
moment of every Hutch stream. I
I pretty strictly ask for timestamps of
Hutch Hutch streams, to be honest with
you.
I I ain't ain't nobody got time for
that. This guy goes on a lot of side
tangents, man. Okay. All right. So,
creepy and weird, creepy and weird,
creepy and weird. What's this one?
Destiny has the group logs going back 2
years
from the group Luna box was talking
about. I've lied about this for like 6
months. Let's see.
>> One thing a lot of them have in common
is that a lot of them have tried their
hand at creating at some point and just
not done very well at it. Like they're
kind of failures. Connor said that just
a little bit ago was in his DMs today
using his divorce as an opportunity to
suck up to him. That's pretty weird and
cringe. But, okay.
I don't think Connor would have
characterized the DMs that way.
I don't think so. Here's what I said to
Connor. Hold on. I'm going to I'm going
to leak my Connor DMs right now.
I don't think Connor would even have a
problem with me leaking it, given that
characterization. I'm going to leak my
DMs to Connor right now.
These are the DMs.
Hey man, I covered your latest stream,
and although I was making I'm making
jokes about stuff during it, I'm
genuinely sorry to hear about the split.
Hope stuff is as good as it can be.
Okay. Hey, I did a stream. I was joking
about you. I was laughing at you. I was
laughing at your pain. But, I hope
you're doing good anyway.
Is that me sucking up to him?
Is that not just like a pretty normal
human thing? Hey, my job is to like
watch content in this space and to laugh
at it. I did that with your pain.
I've done it with a lot of other
people's pain, and they don't even get
the courtesy of a message. There's
honestly a point in that stream where I
I couldn't make a comment cuz Connor was
describing some interpersonal stuff that
I was like was very sad to hear.
And that made me think like, "Hey, I'm
going to let him know, hey, that's like
I'm sorry this is happening, man."
Yeah, I'm just Okay.
Sucking up. What the What the
Okay, uh we keep going.
>> to like Connor said that just a little
bit ago was in his DMs today using his
divorce as an opportunity to suck up to
him. That's pretty weird and cringe. The
final boss is unemployment. There's like
this whole
There's this whole uh
Uh And a maybe have a common thread
amongst them. Like a lot of them are One
thing a lot of them have in common is
that a lot of them have tried their hand
at creating at some point and just not
done very well at it. Like they're kind
of failures. And a lot of them also seem
to share this one thing in common that
they've discovered
>> Okay, never mind. I'm sorry. Okay, you
know what actually it hold on. I'm
sorry. Okay.
>> Guys.
>> I lied about all this for probably like
6 months. Okay.
>> It's here. The master plan is about to
unfold. Okay, this was yesterday I
think. The master plan is about to
unfold guys.
>> One of the big huge drops of my
manifesto is that I've had a person who
is in the server that learner box is
going to talk about who has been logging
the entire server for the better part of
the last two years. Every single thing
that Justical that Kilo and that every
other piece of [__] that's been in the
server that's been coordinating tweets,
coordinating docs, coordinating
harassment, coordinating YouTube videos.
Every single one of them has been for
By the way,
he says I believe he says last two years
to make it seem like it covers his like
court case or something.
It doesn't.
It's not It's flat out not existed for
two years. Not even Not even one year I
don't think.
So, I think he's trying to make it seem
like this could cover his court case and
like
like explain this cabal narrative he
came up with to dox people with. But
he's just lying. He's like a lazy lying
disgusting
pervert, disgusting weirdo. So,
he's just lying. He's just lying. Very
weird.
Think about it. Every single one of them
is trying to scurry around Ethan posted
about the doc server, did he? Somebody
link something about it. Hold on.
That'll be it. I'll have a huge like
search for index of this after my
manifesto. Okay, sorry. These people
everybody been seduced by this once
every few months. Hassan will repost
this and boost this motif. That's kind
of a thing. Um, but I got I don't really
I don't really know if any character
like read the [__] that I'm given for.
So, I don't know what I'm talking about.
Like I don't really stuff like this down
I'm not interested in me. Although some
of the stuff that I've done has been
fascinating. Um, the second one I'll say
is going on for a while and the the two
phases of this um, one question I have
that I got like if you want to make a
video could you make this fine. Um, I
would be curious why they would use
sulfur as like their research director
though. Uh, that was a little bit
jarring to me because
if because I remember quite well. Sulfur
if you guys remember used to be a
moderator in the community. You can
consider them Bro, these people have
[__] up so badly. Suddenly hear
chatter of a secret snark Discord that's
being leaked. I wonder who they've spent
the past two years obsessing over. We
are obsessed with such a with such a
with a person like you. Such a whiny,
worthless, spineless, [__] loser, okay?
We are very obsessed, yes. Everybody is
obsessed with Ethan Klein, yes. The logo
of the server is a skull that has the
letters CPS written on it, yes.
Absolutely.
A dude.
I'm just I'm just telling you
They're They're making this sound so
cool and so awesome. And then they're
trying to be like, "These guys are
unemployed." Okay, and?
We We just That's how passionate people
are.
All right? It's awesome. It's awesome. I
love that I can show up and I can be
like, "Hey,
did somebody watch Hutch's stream
today?"
And a hundred of the
hundred of the most maniacal, funniest,
most
just raise their hands and go, "Yeah, we
all watched it today. Yep, we got all
the timestamps. Yeah, we watch all of
it. Yep." Every single time Every single
time hundred hundred people raise their
hands. "Yeah, we watched the entire
thing."
Yeah, did you watch the H3 podcast, too?
Yes. These people have a hyperbolic time
chamber to analyze all of the content
that's happening
and to snark all of it, okay? We are in
This is the hyperbolic time chamber. All
content will be analyzed. Everything you
say and do will be analyzed. It will be
recorded and we will laugh about it. I'm
sorry to tell you.
It's happening.
It's been happening, okay? Anyway, I
Uh this should be very funny that Ethan
Klein's blowing the server up right now.
Very cool. The best time FOR SNARK IS
NOW. It is now, yes. Oh boy. Hutch is so
gross for swinging his dead sister
around, man.
I'm just I I can basically show people
when that when stuff like that gets
said, like I push back on stuff like
that if it gets said. Guys, don't know I
don't know what to tell other people,
man. Dude, okay. We're going to be
featured on the H3 podcast. I hope I got
some bangers.
We'll see. We'll see what happens. Do
you consider that your I don't know what
that sentence means. She was demoted.
For reasons we've been over a few times.
Oh, we need the we need the L if we need
it. What's happening? One of the reasons
she left was because I had called her
out. I didn't name her, but I just got
to know. I called her out because she
had called me quite strongly to falsely
accuse someone of this harassment. She
had produced this whole like
50-page document because she does that.
She like overwhelms people with
information or like she's got her own
like her whole thing in this Discord was
like to plan arguments. And as soon as
she was losing, she would just tell
people to read the reason why a lot of
them are scurrying now there's a whole
bunch of weird battle lines. I'll go
over all of this when I drop my
manifesto hopefully in 3 weeks or
whatever. just messed up this stupid
case. But like they do so it's so
cringe. Like Substance will workshop
these tweets with like just a goal of
like Doobie and these other Seba and the
I don't even remember their [__]
names. I'm just like Byplane I don't
remember their names. They're just
random losers. But like they workshop
these tweets together. They'll post the
tweet. They tell everybody to like go
and retweet and engage with and juice it
up. They'll give talking points to each
other in these Discords and then
Dude,
every one of my viewers is like, "Oh, so
he's doing that to another space. So
he's actually like being a terrorist in
forcing other spaces to do this, too?"
Yes. Everywhere I have control over, I
will ban you if you don't juice my
tweets. You, okay? This is not a
democracy. I'm a dictator. Juice the
tweet. Juice the tweet now. Dude, people
are complaining about that on Twitter
the other day. They're like, "Jidion
linked the Keemstar video?" And he he
locked the Discord so that people would
engage with it. Everyone of my Discords
like, "Thank you for finally pointing
this out. He's been doing it to us for
years." Yes, I do do that. Yes, I do
that all the time.
And they'll go out and debate like other
people. It's the level of like
coordination is insane. It's unhinged.
How crazy I think what Luna Bots is
talking Dude, the level of the level of
coordination is is crazy. It's unhinged.
It's It's unhinged. Guys, YOU HAVE NO
IDEA
how unhinged and crazy it is.
>> They'll post the tweet. They tell
everybody to like go and retweet and
engage with and juice it up. They'll
give talking points to each other in
these Discords and then they'll go out
and they'll debate like other people.
It's the level of like
So hold on. You know what? Actually,
let's just slow that down and and let's
slow that down and remove the
cult spin, okay? Let's just slow it down
and remove the cult spin. Maybe this is
what we should do. We should be the the
no spin zone, okay?
Uh
I don't I don't remember the answers.
They're just random losers. But like
they work out these tweets together.
They'll post the
They go, "Hey,
what do you guys think of this? Do you
guys think Do you think this would pop
off?" There's a bunch of creators in
there, a bunch of people who are on
Twitter, a bunch of people who are
streamers. They go, "Hey, does this
sound like funny?"
Evil. Absolutely evil. We They tell
everybody to like go and retweet and
engage with and juice it.
They post a tweet and say juice the
tweet.
Absolutely evil. Can't think of anybody
else who's ever done that. Surely we
won't find a bunch of examples of
Destiny posting his tweets for his
community to go and juice, right?
Surely not. Um Look, they're talking
points to each other in these Discords
and then they'll
They'll give talking points to each
other in these Discords. They'll argue
about content with each other
in a group of friendly people with a
shared interest, okay?
All right.
All right. They'll go out and they'll
debate. Does it watch your stream, by
the way? Yeah, that is my thing. Juice
the tweet. Juice the tweet. Juice the
tweet. Juice the tweet. Yes. together in
these Discords and then they'll go out
and they'll debate like other people.
It's the level of like Then they'll go
out and debate other people.
They like standing on business and
standing by their ideas.
Yes.
Imagine that. Imagine just being like,
"Yes, this is what I believe. I will
argue with people." Imagine that, man.
At which was literally on stream crying
about not having more motion on one of
his anti-Hassan tweets at J Stalk. Oh,
that's so cool. Oh my god.
DGG, please. I'm not getting enough
motion on my tweets.
Yeah?
Like
Okay? I mean, that's Listen,
that's normal human interaction. I don't
know why we're trying to take normal
It's because they're inhuman. It's
because Destiny doesn't understand what
it's like to have friends or like a
common interest with other people. He's
basically just operating on himself or
operating by himself, and he's like a
psycho who doesn't have real meaningful
connections.
And so, when he sees other people
working together, he applies like a
Machiavellian lens to it, which is
inappropriate, right? That's not what
anyone's We're just having fun, man.
We're just having fun.
And Destiny's like, "They're like trying
to destroy my life."
Bro, they don't even talk about you.
Well, sorry, they do talk about him in
there, but you're not one of the most
talked about people in there.
It's just a bunch of people having fun,
doing what they enjoy.
Why you got to be a hater, man?
Snarking is legal, okay? Snarking is
legal. Having negative opinions of
Destiny, or Ethan Klein, or Nicholas De
Orio, or any of these losers is totally
legal. If you can point to illegal or
even immoral activity beyond just being
mean to you, go ahead.
We don't want that, right?
We The only person who's ever done
anything close to doxing that server, or
so who's ever done like actual doxing,
like revealing private info of somebody,
was banned.
Okay?
What else is there?
I'm trying to think of like other people
who've been banned. I I try to police
the like tone, to be honest with you,
but
I'm not very successful sometimes.
Anyway, it's It's like not a problem,
though. And I've never told people not
to say like people snark on me in there.
Bro, there's some guy in there who calls
me a a maple monkey every time he's in
chat and I'm in chat, he calls me a
maple monkey.
Am I supposed to WHY ARE YOU SNARKING ON
ME? BAN THIS GUY NOW. BAN THIS GUY RIGHT
NOW.
NO. I don't Dude, it is what it is. It
is what it is, man. What am I supposed
to freak out and be like, "Oh my god,
BAN THIS GET HIM OUT OF HERE. He's mean
to me."
You If you WERE MY FRIENDS, YOU WOULD
BAN this guy. IF YOU WERE MY FRIENDS,
YOU'D DELETE this guy's messages. If you
were my friend, you wouldn't let this
happen.
No.
I literally talk about other people
all the time.
I Why Why would I say you can't talk
[__] about other people?
Coordination is insane. It's unhinged.
How crazy. And I think what Lunar Box is
talking about is So, these people like
obsessively start writing these huge
manifestos and then they try to gaslight
Not gaslight. They try to amplify and
gas up all these toxic people that are
that they perceive amplify and gas Dude,
amplify gaslight gaslight amplify
amplify gaslight juice it up Look at
talking points to each other in these
Discords and then they'll go out and
they'll debate like other people. It's
the level of like coordination is
insane. It's unhinged.
Talking to your friends is insane and
unhinged. Okay. How crazy. And I think
what Lunar Box is talking about is So,
these people like obsessively start
writing these huge manifestos and then
they try to gaslight They obsessively
start writing these huge manifestos.
Example?
They obsessively start writing these
huge manifestos. Is this like My Wand
trying to put together the Beast video
into a video cuz she has a personal
interest?
Like somebody else did a whole bunch of
Dude, by the way, this guy didn't even
write his Keppels manifesto. It was like
everybody else writing that entire
Keppels manifesto with a 10-person group
chat or a 12-person group chat.
How in the world does he Dude, it's so
fake. It's such a fake allegation. They
all lined up and uh thought it was
awesome when he did the Keppels
manifesto with a group chat behind him
who were helping him write it the whole
time. Who he works By the way, I know
for a fact that this lazy This lazy
workshops his tweets in the A-team group
chat. I know he does cuz I've seen
people ask about it.
I've seen people comment on it.
Why is he pretending he doesn't know
what this [__] is? Why is he pretending
that this any different?
So, they did it to Dev a while ago where
they were constantly focused on Dev
short SFO short fat otaku and then
they've done it with um uh they've
They
do it with people who are against us.
Dev is just a liar. Dev is just a weird
liar. Like Why are you Why would you
stand on this? Why would you just stand
on the time Dev lies and he
transparently is like unwilling to admit
that he was lying and he lies more and
he doubles down and he lies and he lies
and he lies. Dude, I didn't I didn't
start pirate software because he was
like against Hassan or against Destiny
or I can't remember where my I can't
remember like
I can't remember who Destiny would say I
was against at that time, okay?
I did it because he kept doubling down
and lying the whole time. Double down,
lie, lie, double down, lie, double down,
lie, double down.
If Dev's going to do the same thing, I'm
going to follow that and laugh at him.
Sorry. They're doing a little bit with
Luna box now even though a lot of these
people like aren't even in my orbit or
whatever, but they're they're just cuz
they haven't made statements that are
strong enough against me or that they're
still too anti-Hassan or whatever. Um,
yeah.
Like some like Yeah, I know Maple Monkey
is funny. That's why I like
Honestly,
no problems with that, okay? It's no
problems with that.
It's a snark community, okay? People be
snarking. Important announcement,
spider, please lend me your ears. Insane
coordination alert.
What is this? Oh, sorry, this is a this
is somebody who's on my team, so to
speak.
Insane coordination alert. This guy's in
two different chats at the same time. Oh
my god. Oh my god.
INSANE COORDINATION IT'S INSANE HOW
coordinated these people are all over
the place. They're all over the place.
Oh my god.
Dude.
>> [clears throat]
>> The funniest part is when they talk
about having like coordination, when
they talk about
this concept of they watch streams
together.
Um, hello, DGG chat?
Guys, guys, it's so disgusting how these
people coordinate and they like watch a
stream together and they snark on the
person. Anyway,
#twitch/hassanabi.
I'm winning, guys, let's go. Embed
Hassan NOW, LET'S WATCH HASSAN. LET'S
SNARK HASSAN. Let's Let's anal gaze
every move and talk about him all the
time. Be totally obsessed. Wow.
It's almost like Destiny getting a taste
of his own medicine. Destiny getting a
taste of what other creators get from
DGG, which is, by the way, totally
legal, totally allowed. But now that
you're under that same lens, you're
freaking the [__] out. You're tearing
your hair out.
Why is that, man? Destiny Destiny looks
in the mirror and he
he abhors what he sees, okay?
What is this creature that stares back
at me?
That's he doesn't like it. He doesn't
like having the mirror held up, okay?
All right. Hutch asked Loadedbox for the
internal server logs. So, I believe
Hutch went on and asked Loadedbox
>> article that some one of my friends put
up on Substack. I'm like, okay, big big
deal.
But then obviously like
I saw their notes for how they were
producing this video and saw the kind of
arguments that they were making or some
of the comments they were having on my
stream as they were watching it um
from me talking about the issue and I
just thought it was like very kind of
funny and how flagrantly dishonest and
poorly like argued it was. So, yeah, I
just commented on that yesterday and
also yesterday I got sent like the full
logs of the uh the server from this
internal
turncoat, I guess.
Um
Oh my god. And yeah, I just mentioned
that as well. And now it's I guess it's
been a bit of a big life event for these
people.
Wait, can you send me the logs? Can I
get the logs? Uh I'll have to ask my
mole, okay?
I mean, I've seen some pretty Have you
named any names? Are there Is there
anybody in there that I that is like
familiar to me?
Uh yeah. Oh, I have to see these logs,
dude. I have to see them. I have to like
listen and tell your mom so I'm so
trustworthy
about this kind of stuff. I would never
ever ever I won't even I won't even put
it on my work computer.
Yeah, okay. So, listen, I'm going to I'm
going to I'm going to pull up a big list
here, okay? And there's a list of all
the people who have asked me for more
information about the server and access
to these logs, okay? There's a huge
queue forming up. I'm I'm starting to I
Yesterday I was thinking I should
actually start taking bids, you know? My
allegiance is to the highest bidder.
[clears throat]
And then I found out Destiny already has
them, so now I'm annoyed.
Um
But you know, you know.
I'm sure that given what I've seen,
there are definitely some people who
would pay a who would not pay for a
penny for that, you know, like Ethan
Klein.
>> This is before the wild logs, by the
way. Dan Saltman and the wild logs and
yeah,
assuming Destiny doesn't show it to Dan
for some whatever reason. So, Okay,
anyway, Destiny has the logs and Hutch
asked for them. Okay.
We watched
this one? Yeah, we watched this one.
We're going up to them now. Okay.
So, here's another one.
We'll we'll explain all of these or
we'll we'll look through all of them,
okay?
So, man, imagine shooting yourself in
the foot this hard. Turning private
community drama into doxing allegations,
dragging unrelated stream streamers into
it, brigading other streamer chats, and
having screenshots where the apparent
focus is taking talking about other
creators and logging them while somehow
expecting to come out looking good.
Genuinely incredible self-sabotage.
Uh no, nobody thinks like anyone here is
going to look good. All we want is for
you to admit that you don't care about
like the truth about, you know, the
truth of what's being said at all.
You're just mad cuz people are are being
mean to you.
So, no
unethical conduct.
Right? So, that when people get mad,
when they get asked mad about this,
their only argument boils down to,
"You're being mean to me." That's the
goal, okay? So, that the output of the
server is not affected. Okay? As
Queenman say, "Okay, I'm going to be
real." Left would have been banned after
Perry's covered in Acandros. I'm going
to lose it if Perry versus Kathy versus
Ricky, whatever, keeps coming up.
And this is basically trying to hit
Queenman, right? Wait, so the chat got
purged. Someone please resend the
preserve tube link to run right back.
It's not just Cole, it's literally
everyone shooting themselves in the foot
repeatedly and everyone involved should
be totally ashamed. Guess what? Internal
community doxing drama looks terrible on
everyone. So, how about don't be a
Oh, can't say that word. Send IP sending
IP grabbers and don't blow it up on six
streams when you've been palling around
with the guy doing it for a year.
Well, I So, what Dude, I don't know what
the underlying drama is here. Like, I'm
pretty unaware.
But, I know that Queen Man's saying you
guys can't do this. So, I'll give you
what I think it is. I think it was like
somebody in this server as a joke had as
a joke They're saying as a joke, which I
think a lot of people believe is a joke.
Okay? Even I think the people who were
in the servers where it happened believe
it was a joke until they basically got
in a fight.
But, he sent a link that was like
there's some website you can put you
could It's like a short URL thing that
records the IP of anybody who clicks on
it.
And I think he sent something like that
in one of these chats or in one of these
Discords. Not in this Discord, in a
different Discord. Nothing was ever done
with it. I don't think anything ever
happened. But, what Queen Man's saying
there is, "Hey, it looks bad when you
guys have these kinds of fights cuz then
it like basically makes it look like
there's a crazy [__] going on in here
when there's not. But, it makes it like
other people with bad intentions who are
not going to treat you with good faith,
who don't understand you at all could
possibly paint it that way."
The The fact is is like if you want to
be in that Discord, don't make jokes
like that or you could just go.
Right?
Like, it would be my opinion, too. If
you're going to make a joke like that,
[__] off.
Don't be around.
Like, we're we're clipping. We're like
actually, you know, in this thing trying
to make like content happen. Trying to
make awesome content happen. And you're
doing in like a in like a 10 like a
five-viewer streamer's Discord, you're
posting a link like this that could look
bad. Like, [__] off.
Don't do it.
There anyone that was really obsessed
with Ethan Klein? I mean, Kathy doesn't
like Ethan Klein.
Kathy That's Kathy's the person who
snarks Ethan Klein like the most. Kathy
doesn't like Ethan Klein. But, we love
We love Kathy. We love Kathy. Well,
sometimes. Kathy can be funny. Kathy is
unreliable sometimes, okay?
Little little unreliable sometimes.
Did you run the video through your local
synagogue? I made it anti-semite proof.
You're criticizing Of course, he'll call
it anti-semitic. And this is being
framed as good faith criticism? How
Wait, how would it not be good faith
criticism?
How does a joke from the creator of the
video
about Ethan Klein's propensity to call
everything anti-semitism because he is a
like histrionic loser, how does that
have anything to do
with the good faith criticism, bad faith
criticism?
Taking the ADL. Oh god, spider
roast. What is wrong with Spider-Man?
Why would you do this? You tagged the
ADL? Uh-huh, okay. At Charlie Kirk 11,
okay, that's funny. I didn't say spider
was smart. I did not say spider was
smart.
I did not say that. I've never once said
that. I would absolutely never say that,
okay?
I said I thought he was better than
this. I thought he had a good heart.
I This is not a good heart. It's a
tainted heart, okay?
So, this is another out of context log.
You don't see anything around it, right?
And this in and of itself, Ethan Klein
objectively by it by any measure outside
of like an ADL's like the ADL
spokespeople
Ethan Klein over accuses people of
anti-semitism. He turns a lot of the
critiques of him into anti-semitism. He
always wonders if people are being
anti-semitic. This is just a joke.
Holy [__]
Hutch reacts to Lonerbox calling out Mod
Sulfur over pushing false dude.
Calls her out. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
>> I didn't name her. He's going to make a
face.
Yeah, he's just going to make a face at
the camera.
He used this whole like 50-page document
>> Dude, it's going to be so easy.
To any remotely neutral third party,
this guy is like a total [snorts]
liability.
I just I love Listen, it's like
Stardust, Hutch, Spider,
Dan, Destiny, Willy Mac.
Oh my god.
Dude, all Oh, we've got I'm I'm Dude,
can I find the tweet? Where's the tweet?
Where's the tweet?
Dude,
judge me. Judge me by my enemies. Judge
me by my enemies, guys.
Wick, yeah, Wick.
My god.
I think Wick was posting about how like,
"Oh, it's so obvious these guys were
doing crazy the whole time." Okay, can
tell you haven't seen anything.
All right. I think this is the last one
we need to watch to really dig into
today, okay? I think this is the last
one that's very important to get into.
This is the big smear that pissed
everybody off. I think we're like
I wanted to like slow play this and let
them talk about stuff, but this is the
big smear that if this had happened
while I was awake, I would have said,
"No. No, these guys." Like we're going
to we're going to actually start
responding cuz holy [__]
So, this smear was gross to me that
Shmoo and Nikacado are both like big
up-and-coming YouTubers. Nikacado's
Shmoo, Nikacado.
And to try to like derail them or or
accuse them of doxxing when it's really
not doxxing what's going on here at all,
it's just goofy, okay?
So,
caught using doxxing tools to unmask
anonymous X users in the Snark Discord.
Wick logs, this didn't happen. Spider is
illiterate. Wick logs show discussion of
using doxxing tools.
Uh this is true that there was some I
think Nikacado mentions a tool here.
Tracking username history and trying to
pressure anonymous accounts into
revealing personal information before
the conversation moved to private
channels. Anyone know how to do how to
gay off them into revealing more info?
Run the doxx tool.
Let's see. Let's see. Let's see. Context
Redacted is a Twitter account that Shmoo
came across and wants to know the
identity of. They only they suspect it
of being a Tectone one of Tectone's alts
or a mod. Other unrelated names are
redacted as well. Doxx tool one and doxx
tool two are websites to find the
personal personally identifiable
information on it by on any username.
You can receive things such as past
usernames, real name, address, email,
breach passwords, photos, and other
information.
So,
Nikandros posts a picture. That redacted
guy is 100% someone's alt or something.
Techy?
So, basically what I think Shemuel and
Nikandros are talking about here and
what
What's what this accusation is
implicitly trying to do is
it's trying to discredit people
for like by making illegitimate
accusations.
And as a consequence,
right? As a consequence, how is Hutch
gross? He's a lying, manipulative,
disgusting loser who is not willing to
show any grace to his friends in the
same way they show grace to him.
I find that disgusting personally. And I
can prove this very easily. We're not
going to do it today, but I can prove
very easily.
Anyway, we keep reading. So, they want
to use this smear to go after Nikandros
and Shemuel, essentially, effectively
protecting TechTone. They're trying to
smear these two people who are saying,
"Hey, we want to make sure that Pink
here has evidence for her What is it?
Her protective order, right? To maintain
her protective order, to possibly
enforce
like some kind of violation. Now, I
can't imagine What What kind of space do
you guys think it would be that they're
going to really get upset about trying
to find basically if this guy's a
TechTone mod and to pass that on to a
victim of a crime, to pass that on to a
like a assault victim.
What kind of What kind of space is like,
"Oh, oh we hate We hate the other people
in this space so much that we're going
to take these two who are just trying to
help out somebody who was a victim of
assault?"
And we're going to try to degrade them,
to denigrate them, to smear them, to go
after them.
Anyway, we keep reading.
They're They're trying to protect
TechTone. They're trying to undermine, I
guess, Pink and they're going after
these two to do it. Let's Let's actually
look at what the allegation is. Let's
look what's actually happening here.
That redacted guy's 100% someone's alt
or something. Techy?
I don't know who, but that uh unrelated
redacted person is in redacted state and
is personal friends with Tectone.
Related redacted. And they also hate
unrelated redacted.
Okay, so what? This is Pink and then
unrelated redacted is in redacted state.
Anyone know how to gay up them into
revealing more info?
It could just be a personal friend of
Tectone as well, but definitely
something going on
definitely something going on there. I'm
not sure his viewers even know he's
friends with unrelated redacted or not.
Anyone know how to gay up them into
revealing more info? It could be a
personal friend to Tectone as well, but
definitely something going on there. I'm
not sure his viewers even know he's
friends with unrelated redacted or not.
So this is Novaru, okay?
Uh Tectone is way too obsessed not to do
something like this. Language analysis
stat. Mr.
Mr. would indicate they're male.
What was the name of the account? So
they're trying to figure out if this is
somebody related to Tectone. So
basically they're bunch of people who
are participating in a coordinated smear
against Pinky Cheeks. Like there were
creators talking about how Tectone was
sending them documents and stuff.
Right? And that is against the
protective order. And so I think what
they're looking for is evidence of that
happening again. Any evidence of
of like Tectone reaching out to third
parties, which he's not allowed to do,
to give them info on Pinky Cheeks so
that they can disparage her. That is
against the protective order.
Okay?
Against it. And so they're they're
thinking Nikacros has a hunch that this
is somebody related. Uh there's no
redacted on Steam. I guess it's the the
name of the person they're looking at.
Could be be unique enough to look it up
through this thing. That person might be
enough to have another account
somewhere.
Uh redacted image one. Clumsy attempt at
woke scolding? No, it's just So they're
pondering this person's identity.
Right?
Now
this could this does seem like a little
odd to me. You're like asking about this
person randomly. But is it like is it
doxxing? No.
Um maybe So, Nikandros is pretty
comfortable looking up like stuff like
this, I guess. But, that's cuz he's had
to like he he makes videos, right?
So, he'll investigate stuff like this.
He's pretty not afraid to just say like,
"Yeah, I'll look stuff up." He's very
very very careful about what he's
revealed. I don't believe there's any
credible allegation of Nikandros doxing
anybody. He is incredibly incredibly
careful with any information he's going
to publicize. So, you can say this looks
weird, but I would say with the track
record that Nikandros has built over
multiple videos of never revealing info,
of actually reaching out to people and
letting them know that they're giving
too much info away. He has He basically
has a track record of doing this. That
if he's like investigating people, he'd
give them a heads-up like, "Hey, just so
you know, you've got like a bunch of
data out here and like I'm not doing
anything with it. I promise I'll never
reveal it, but you need to do something
about this."
Okay? So, I just think when he's got
that track record, I'm not as I
personally feel like I'm not as
concerned about him, you know, talking
about this.
I would prefer he didn't do it in a like
100% Discord, right? But, it's like it's
like maybe a bad look
in some way.
Okay, anyway.
Okay, clumsy attempt at woke scolding.
Redacted image, redacted image. Could
just be one of his mods, I guess, his
followers. From my POV, this redacted
guy is some [__] who wanted who watched
my video and seemed to agree with that.
I doubt it's him.
Yeah, it's most likely the most likely
thing is it's a mod or something, but I
guess it specifically follows Pink just
to do [__] like this.
They had two username changes, run the
blank docs tool, too. These are like
We'll get more information on this from
the chat conversation, all right? Uh
also, these memes they post fake plastic
That's Freud tongue, a Freudian slip. A
Freudian slip.
File that away for later. 100% Freud.
So, he's saying this is probably a
woman.
Who the [__] even knows what the names
of these girls are? Spectate is already
zoned the the in, noticed them calling
Rev a sweet person.
I don't know who that is.
Um, this guy's Twitter ID is redacted,
so finding whatever their account's old
username was, chat messages from Nick
Fuentes and Shmu now move to voice or
direct messages with public chats from
them ending completely at this point.
Okay, so this allegation is essentially
there's nobody doxed here, right? What
they're trying to do is they they're
trying to see if they can connect this
to another person that's connected to
Techtone.
And but connected through a pseudonym to
Techtone, right? They're trying to see
would this be another Twitter user,
would this be another person like with a
pseudonym? And if that pseudonym has
like an identity, then that could be if
you published it doxing. I think if you
connect like a a public identity to a
private one, that is a form of doxing.
Now, with any form of doxing, there is
like there is obviously the Taylor
Lorenz example's a good one. I didn't
get a chance to highlight it this
morning, but I think Dan was talking
about how some of these people support
Taylor Lorenz and she doxed Libs of
TikTok. There's a public interest
argument for doxing.
Libs of TikTok was doxing and harassing
and calling for multiple people to be
fired. I believe they got people fired
from their jobs. Right? Libs of TikTok
was a serial doxer.
That is why it's in the public interest
to know the identity of Libs of TikTok.
Now, the bar for finding out if they're
a serial harasser is high. With Libs of
TikTok, they admitted to it. They said
they did it.
The way DG Yid here, this is like, oh,
so you think defensive doxing is a
thing? Well, you have to prove the
person was doxing.
Right? You can't just you can't just
say they doxed somebody and then dox
them.
Like
like you can't you can't totally
fabricate a self-defense incident. Say,
oh, this person may be threatened when
they were facing the other direction,
right? And then shoot them in the back
and go, "Ha, that was self-defense. No,
I have a I have proof of a conspiracy
that this guy was talking to somebody
who was talking to somebody who was
talking to somebody who was going to
shoot me."
It was self-defense. That doesn't work,
bro.